أعتقد أن المستهلكين يريدون بوضوح هذه
الأنواع من بدائل اللحوم وهذا هو
السبب في أنك ترى تايسون يفعل ذلك
بقليل من الهجين لأنه كما ذكرت
يوجد بياض بيض هناك ، لذا
فأنت لا تعرف تمامًا أن الحيوانات خالية
بالطريقة التي تتجاوز اللحوم P  البروتينات الأساسية
هي إذن لديك حتى كنتاكي فرايد تشيكن ، أعني أن
C تعني الدجاج الذي سيقومون
به باختبار Nuggets الذي
تعرف المملكة المتحدة مع فطر مخمر
مثل البروتين وهو فطر مخمر الآن
وهذا بالتأكيد تعادل ولكن  ترى
أن هذه العناصر الموجودة في هذه القوائم
لمطاعم الوجبات السريعة هذه تتمتع
ببعض القوة هنا ، نعم أعتقد
أنها بالتأكيد تفعل ذلك ، أعني أنه من الواضح أن
برجر كنج قد حقق نجاحًا مع
الهائل المستحيل ومن الممكن مرة أخرى
هو المنافس الرئيسي لما وراءه  أنا ما وراء اللحوم
تعمل أيضًا مع الكثير من شركات الوجبات السريعة
بما في ذلك
ابن عم شركة برجر كنجز تيم هورتونز على
فطيرة نقانق إذا كنت تريد
نقانق الإفطار المصنوعة من اللحوم المصنوعة من
النباتات  بديل لذلك أعتقد أن
سلاسل الوجبات السريعة تدرك بوضوح أن
المستهلكين ، وخاصة الأصغر سنًا منهم أكثر
وعياً بالصحة ، والذين يشعرون بالقلق أيضًا بشأن
البيئة يريدون هذه الأنواع من الأشياء
في القائمة وما وراء اللحوم إلى
رصيدها ، كما أن توزيع التجزئة
أيضًا يمكنك الذهاب وشراءها  الفطائر
في الكثير من المتاجر لا يزال من المستحيل العمل
على توزيع البقالة